[Musique]
la deuxième journée régionale sur la
réhabilitation psychosociale à la
réunion s'est tenue le 18 octobre à
l'iut de saint-pierre
une journée pour parler de l'accès du
maintien dans le logement des personnes
souffrant de troubles psychiques sévère
et durable
aujourd'hui nous avons 130 personnes et
les professionnels mais aussi des
personnes accompagnées c'est à dire des
locataires des personnes qui sont
passées par par l'errance qui sont
passés qui passent encore peut-être par
un accompagnement au logement ou par un
retour au logement après un passage en
institution les professionnels viennent
d'horizons divers ils sont du champ de
la santé mentale
ils sont du champ du social notamment
ceux en lien avec l'hébergement
d'urgence et l'appui aux au logement
ils sont aussi du champ médico-social
avons aussi des bailleurs sociaux sont
présents à cette journée là le fsl fonds
de solidarité pour le logement constitue
un levier financier du plan
départemental d'action pour le logement
et l'hébergement des personnes
défavorisées
il a été créé pour accorder des aides
aux ménages qui éprouvent des
difficultés pour accéder à un logement
ou pour s'y maintenir
donc on a le volet
bien sûr médico social géré par la
direction du tout lui et on a
pour les personnes qui sont à domicile
donc qu'ils vont être en milieu
ordinaire pouvoir bénéficier de cet
asservissement qs et des services pour
les aider dans les actes de la vie
quotidienne les accompagner les amener
vers de l'autonomie pouvoir
préparez manger pouvoir gérer
de futurs pouvoir apprendre les actes de
la vie quotidienne et pouvoir habiter de
manière autonome dans ce donjon le fonds
de solidarité pour le logement pour
finalité d'insérer à terme durablement
des personnes dans un logement décent et
indépendant
ce dispositif a pour mission donc
l'accompagnement des familles donc à
l'accès et le maintien dans le logement
la porte d'entrée bien évidemment sur le
logement
nous finançons des postes de
travailleurs sociaux dédiés donc
qui travaillent dans différentes
structures agrées ces travailleurs
sociaux interviennent donc auprès des
familles donc relation de proximité
interventions de proximité dans les
familles avec différents axes
d'intervention il s'agit d'accompagner
la famille a accédé
donc c'est l'utilisation à bon escient
de logements des parties communes
apprendre à gérer son budget a anticipé
les dépenses donc c'est extrêmement
important pour la famille puisse se
maintenir dans son logement lui est fait
c s inscrit dans le cadre d'un plan
daide coordonnées organisées en lien
avec la famille et les partenaires
susceptibles d'intervenir
[Musique]